[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا اهلا وسهلا بكم قتل اكثر من 70
شخصا وجرح اكثر من 100 في ثلاثه تفجيرات
بالعاصمه العراقيه بغداد يوم الثلاثاء
تاتي هذه التفجيرات ضمن موجه هجمات ضربت
بغداد خلال الايام السته الماضيه واوقعت
اكثر من 100 قتيل نتوقف في هذا الخبر مع
هذا الخبر لنناقش في محورين ما دلاله وقوع
هذا الكم من الهجمات على احياء بغداد
مؤخرا وكيف يمكن تفسير عجز الاجهزه
الامنيه عن
مواجهته
وما هي الخطوات التي يجب ان تتخذها
الحكومه العراقيه لوقف هذا النسف المستمر
لدماء العراقيين في بغداد
[موسيقى]
وغيرها في مدينه الصدر شرق بغداد وفي سوق
شعبي بحي الشعب في شقها الشمالي كما في
منطقه الرشيد جنوبها ضربت التفجيرات
والهجمات الانتحاريه يوم الثلاثاء
فاوقعت عشرات القتلى واكثر منهم من
المصابين بيد ان هجمات الثلاثاء على
بشاعتها لم تكن سوى حلقه في سلسله تفجيرات
ضربت بغداد فاسقطت خلال الايام السته
الماضيه اكثر من 100 قتيل امر فجر حاله من
الغضب والاستياء وسط سكان بغداد واثار
اسئله بشهن عجز الحكومه والاجهزه الامنيه
عن حما حيه
المواطنين تقرير فاطمه
تريكي ثلاثاء اسود في بغداد نحو 70 قتيلا
من ابناء الفقراء سقطوا حتى ساعات المساء
فقط في سلسله تفجيرات بعضها انتحاري
اكبرها في حي الشعب الشمالي ذي الغالبيه
الشيعيه تبناه تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
هناك وقع العدد الاكبر من الضحايا ثم
انفجار ثان في مدينه الص
تمناه التنظيم ايضا
فثالثة يلم الاهالي جثث بعضهم ويتجهون صوب
المقابر او المشافي ويحدث اي يفيض بهم
فيخرج غاضبين يسالون اين اجهزه الامن واين
وزير الداخليه القادم من ميليشيا بدر
المتهمه بارتكاب جرائم حرب الى موقع حافظ
الامن الاول اين غرف العمليات وقوات
الطوارئ والميزانيات التي تصرف اين واين
واين لا جواب ولا من يتحمل المسؤوليه
اللافت في تف جيرات الثلاثاء ان رئيس
الوزراء حيدر العبادي اقال المسؤول الامني
عن منطقه الشعب حيث وقع التفجير الاول
وترك مسؤولي باقي المناطق من خبره تراكمت
قال عراقيون ان العقاب الاداري نزل على
الارجح بمن لا ظهير حزبيا له التردي
الامني الذي يقارب حاله الانهيار يقود الى
المعادله المعروفه بان الامن ابن
الاستقرار السياسي والعراق المتخبط في
امراضه السياسيه منذ 13 عاما يعيش اليوم
حاله شلل برلمان معطل حكومه غير منتجه
وكتل سياسيه كل منها يغني على مصالحه اما
القوى العسكريه فعلى شاكله شقيقتها
السياسيه خليط من ميليشيات واركان ينخرها
الطائفيه والفساد وتواجه تنظيما شرسا يرى
كثيرون انه هو نفسه احد ابناء الاعتلال
المزمن ينسحب التنظيم تحت النيران الكثيفه
ثم يعود يتراجع ثم يضرب ويختبئ ثم يهاجم
ويفجر حروب تبدو بلا نهايه في بلد مفتوح
على الالم
والمجهول
ونناقش موضوع حلقتنا هذا مع ضيفين من
بغداد عبد الكريم خلف الخبير الامني
والاستراتيجي ومع الدكتور قحطان الخفاجي
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه النهرين
نرحب بضيفي اذا وابدا معك استاذ عبد
الكريم خلف يعني هذه الهجمات تطرح اسئله
كثيره يعني هناك وزاره داخليه هناك قياده
عمليات بغداد هناك وزاره الامن الوطني
هناك اجهزه
استخباراتيه كثيره وعديده في العراق من
يتحمل مسؤوليه الامن في بغداد
اليوم الحقيقه قيادات العمليات غير مسؤوله
عن هذه القضيه على الاطلاق يعني قيادات
العمليات تتحرك بمعلومات هي
قيادات عندما تتاثر لها المعلومات
التفصيليه عن هذا العمل الاجرامي او ذاك
تقوم باستهدافه عن طريق القوى المسلحه ولا
يمكن التكهن ب قضيه وجود سياج بشري ينتظر
ماده متفجره ان ينجح او لا ينجح هذه هذا
النوع من الاعمال الارهابيه لا توقفها
ملايين الجنود عندما تنتشر بالشوارع الذي
يوقف هذه الاعمال هو المعلومه
الاستخباراتيه الصحيحه والدقه في هذه
مسؤوليه الاجهزه الامنيه
الاستخباراتيه واقصد فيها الاجهزه الثلاث
المسؤوله عن جمع المعلومات ووضعها على
طاوله العمليات لكي تتحول الى تنفيذ اللي
يحصل الان لدينا خلل في بنيه هذه الاجهزه
التي الان هي موجوده على انقاض جهاز عمره
اكثر من 100 سنه اجهزه عمره اكر تقصد ان
هذه الاجهزه الاستخباراتيه اجهزه فاشله
هذه الاجهزه ليست فاشله ولكن قدراتها
محدوده بسبب انها تم يعني بشخصه قلم من
السيد بريمر تم تدمير الاجهزه اللي عمرها
100 سنه ولم يتم الاستفاده لا من الكوادر
الوسطى ولا من البنى التحتيه لاجهزه
الاستخبارات التي عمرها طويل واثبتت كفاءه
وقدره في المنطقه وكان الجميع يعلم من هي
اجهزه الاستخبارات العراقيه ولكن حسبت على
النظام السابق واعطيت شت داون والان هذا
البناء الجديد الاجهزه يحتاج الى وقت
وادوات وتدريب ومهارات وتقنيات ومصادر
معلومات وقاعده كبيره من العمل حتى تنهض
بمسؤولياتها مع هذا هذه الاجهزه نجحت في
الميدان واخفق في المدن والسبب انها تحتاج
الى جمله من الاجراءات والجرعات التي
تجعلها تنهض بمسؤولياتها وهذه ربما عامل
الوقت سيكون حائلا او حاسما في هذه القضيه
عندما نقوم بتنميه قدرات الاستخبارات في
تنميه قاعده معلومات بوسا
بتجنيد عدد كبير من المصادر بتوسيع نفوذ
هذه الاجهزه بتغطيتها بقانون لحد الان
جهاز مكافحه الارهاب لم يوافق عليه
البرلمان باي قانون ولم يغطي اجهزه
الاستخبارات الاخرى بقوانين ولم يقم هذا
البرلمان بجعل ايدي هذه الاجهزه طويله طيب
هذه الاجهزه اذا اذا كانت عاجزه الى هذا
الحد والسؤال لدكتور قحطان الخفاجي لماذا
لا نقول ان هذه الاجهزه الامنيه اكثر
مخترق طائفيا كما يرى كثيرون وحاكم
الزاملي رئيس لجنه الامن والدفاع في
البرلمان اتهم وزير الداخليه العراقي
بالانشغال بامور اخرى وب تسخير امكانيات
الوزاره اي وزاره الداخليه لتامين مقرات
المقرات الحزبيه بدل حمايه او توفير
الحمايه للمواطنين ما رايك بهذا
الكلام حياك الله اختي العزيزه وحي الله
المشاهدين وضيف الكريم وقبل هذا وذاك ندعو
ال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يرحم شهدائنا
وان يمن برحمته الواسعه على
الجرحه انا اشاطر الاخ الاستاذ الكريم على
ما ذهب اليه ولكن المواطن العراقي يسال
اذا كانت هذه الصوره واضحه لهذه الدرجه
لدى المسؤولين والسيد المتحدث كان بالامس
القريب احد اعضاء الاساسيين في الداخليه
فماذا ذنب الشعب العراقي يتحمل هذه الاخ
خطاء جميعها وما ذنب العراق ان تبقى ذات
الجهات وذات المسؤولين على قمه السلطه
الاداريه نعم حياك انا انا اتي في الكلام
ومن مسؤول عن هذا الا فشل الامني برايمر
اذا
جاء به
وجيء باخرين على قمه سلطه الدوله باراده
امريكيه وحل الجيش العراقي السابق لما لا
يعاد الجيش العراقي السابق
اخرى لماذا يكون الانتقائيه في الاعاده
لماذا تكون هذه الاليه التي تم بها تاسيس
جيش عراقي او حتى الاجهزه الامنيه غير
مهنيه طائفيه مذهبيه ما يسمى بالدمج عناصر
غير كفؤ لام مهنيه فيها والمشكله الكبرى
التي اؤكد واعيد ما قال استاذ العزيز ان
لو اتينا بطوابير من الجيش لا يمكن ان يرد
انتحاري يرد الانتحاري الصوره التاليه او
بالنقطه التاليه عندما ننزع فتيل الخلاف
العقائدي الفكري في المجتمع العراقي واحد
وعندما يكون لنا قدره استخباريه استباقيه
دقيقه تخترق الطرف الاخر المساله معكوسه
تماما
لدينا تهري فكري في داخل مجتمعنا العراقي
وسما الاحزاب السياسيه واحد ولدينا اجهزه
امنيه لا يمكن ان نصفها اجهزه امنيه الا
انها اجهزه مستفيده ذات لنفسها احالت
الامور الى ما ال اذا نحن نقول
كاستراتيجيه الاجهزه الامنيه ولماذا لا
يتم اجراء سليم صحيح يخرج العراق من ازمته
ايضا انا اقول المشكله الاساسيه ان لا احد
في هرم الدوله العراقيه ساعي بجديه لان
يمسك الخيوط الحقيقيه لتوصله الى النتيجه
لان همه الاول والاخير كيف يملا جيوبه
وكيف يرضي من اتى به الى السلطه هل توافق
على هذا الكلام الاستاذ عبد الكريم خلف
اهم المسؤول اليوم هو كيف يملا جيوبه
يقول
دكتور الاستاذ قحطان الخفاجي
لكن المسؤول في النهايه سواء كان وزير او
مسؤول امني وظيفته كمسؤول تنفيذي هي حمايه
المواطنين وحاكم الزاملي نفسه قال يعني
وزير الداخليه المسؤول الاول عن الامن
مشغول باشياء اخرى يؤمن المقرات الحزبيه
ولا يهم لا من قريب ولا من بعيد مساله
تامين الحمايه للمواطنين ما مدى خطوره هذه
الظاهره هي المشكله سيدتي في قضيه البنيه
السياسيه والبنيه الهيكليه للاجهزه
الامنيه البنيه السياسيه اللي بني عليها
كل المنظومه السياسيه الان لو لاحظنا حتى
ولو حققنا قفزات في قضيه اعاده هيكله
اجهزه الامن وحققنا نتائج يعني الان الجيش
يحقق مكاسب يعني قبل ساعات تم السيطره على
مدينه الرطبه ولم يبقى لدينا الكثير في
قضيه الانبار ولكن المشكله السياسيه يعني
حتى ولو كانت اجهزه الاستخبارات قادره على
الوصول للمعلومه وتقدم الامن سيبقى هذا
الصراع قائم ودائم الا اذا خطت المنظومه
السياسيه خطوات لمساعده الاجهزه الامنيه
في طمانه الحاضنات التي يتحرك فيها داعش
بحريه وهي كبيره جدا لا يمكن يعني عن
عندما الحاضنات ترى داعش انه غير عدو حتى
ولو لم تشاركه القتال ولكنه تراه انه ليس
عدوا بمعنى ان هناك خللا في هذه الدوله
يجب ان يعاد النظر فيه ويعاد النظر فيه
بتشريعات وقوانين تجعل من هذه البيئه
نافره لداعش ثم اجهزه الامن تقوم بجهد
يقتصر على بعض المجامع صغيرها وكبيرها
ولكنها تكون محدوده اما بهذا الحجم يعني
حجم الان نواجه جيشا من الارهابيين في
نينوى وفي في شمال صلاح الدين وفي الانبار
وفي الحدود يعني هناك خلل هذا الخلل يجب
ان يلتفت له الساسه 13 سنه من الفشل يجب
ان يعاد النظر فيها بطريقه تجعل من اداء
الاجهزه الامنيه اداء يعني واقعيا لا يوجد
جهاز امني في العالم يواجه هذه الجيوش
الارهابيه بهذا الحجم ونريد منه نجاحا
مستمرا هذا الصراع اذا ما استمر بهذه
الطريقه سيستنزف موارد الدوله وموارد
البشر داعش قرر نقل المعارك الى المدن بعد
ان فش في الميدان ونقل المعارك الى المدن
عملا صعبا ليس لداعش سهل ولكن على الاجهزه
الامنيه صعبا لانها عشرات او مئات الاف
الاهداف المنتشره على طول البلاد وعرضها
ستكون اهداف لداعش وسوف لن يميز بين هدفا
واخر المهم هو في هذا يريد ان يستفز بعض
الحاضنات الشيعيه لكي ترد على المناطق
السنيه وبهذا يكون داعش قد ربحت الجوله
لحد الان لم يكن هناك ردا ولكن استمرار
الضغط على هذه المناطق قاع الضحايا بهذا
الحجم وهذه المذابح ربما تجعل من الامر
يسء اكثر ولهذا نخشى من هذا الانفلات داعش
عندما يخسر في مناطق حيويه
واستراتيجيه تهدده وجوديا في كل العراق
خسارته في الانبار هو يعرف مداها ويعرف ما
هو الثمن الذي ستدفعه هذه هذا التنظيم
المجرم في كل البلاد نعم ولكن حكم سم يقول
هذه تفجيرات في مدينه الصدر هي بسبب
مطالبه
الصدريين بالاصلاح ومقتدى الصدر قبل قليل
نفسه قال هذه الهجمات دليل وسؤال لدكتور
قحطان خفاجي مقتضى الصدر قال هذه الهجمات
دليل على عجز الحكومه التي لم تنجح ابدا
في حمايه المواطنين العراقيين بعد ان نهبت
وسرقت خيرات العراقيين ما
رايك اصاب كبل وقال وقال اضيف فقط انه قال
كلام مهم قال انها ت تستخدم لتصفيه
الحسابات
السياسيه اكيد ولكن هنا اتمنى ان يسمعني
الاخ الصدر ان لا ينزلق يعني وهو حكيم
باذن الله و متربي تربيه الوطنيه سليمه
الى حيث يتمنى الخصم يتمنى العدو العدو
يتمنى ان تدار المعركه او تنقل المعركه
فعلا الى ليس كما قال زميلي قبل قليل ما
بين بالسنه والشيعه وهذا المسمى ابرا الى
الله من هذا مسميين ولكن الخصم يتمنى ان
تنقل الامور او الخلافات بين المكون
الواحد ايضا منين قوس المكون الشيعي حصرا
لذلك انا هنا احذر اخوتي الذين لديهم يد
مؤثره على الجماعات المسلحه في هذا التكتل
ان ينزلق الى حيث المهت لان المهت قد تذهب
الى ايادي خبيثه هنا وهناك وتوظف في هذا
الاتجاه انا اتوقعت تكرار حالتين تفجيرين
بهذا الحجم في مدينه الصدر اللي هي الثوره
ونعتز بهذا اسم الثائر على طول الخط وفي
منطقه الشعب ايضا هي عمليه راد لها ان
تعطى دلاله على ان خلاف شيعي شيعي وراء
هذه العمليه انا هنا وال واعين ان شاء
الله كثر نعي هذه الحاله هذا مراد للعدو
داعش وسواه هنا اتمنى ان يمسكوا زمام
المبادره وزمام التوجيه وحتى في التصريحات
ارجو ان لا ينزلق في بعض التصريحات الى ما
تؤجج هذه الحاله انا اقول دائما ولست هنا
مادحا للداعين الذين بلانا وابتلينا بهم
انهم ذكاء عالي لديهم يستطيعون ان يستغلوا
ضعف الاجهزه الامنيه ويستغلوا الخلاف
السياسي القائم حالي لذلك ذهبوا الى حيث
الخلاف الدقيق بين جماعتين شيعي ين طفح
هذا الخلاف على السطح وهناك مناوشات بينهم
ذهب هذا العدو بذكاء بين قوسين مكر الى
حيث منطقه الصدر وذا ما قاله حيدر العبادي
من ان التنظيم يستغل نعم من ان تنظيم
الدوله يستغل حاله الشلل السياسي هذا ما
سنناقشه بعد الفاصل يعني
سنناقش البعد المطلوب من الحكومه لوضع حد
للتدهور الامني في بغداد وفي بقيه انحاء
العراق ولكن بعد فاصل قصير لا تذهبوا
[موسيقى]
بعيدا مشاهدينا اهلا وسهلا بكم من جديد
الى هذه الحلقه التي تناقش مستقبل الاوضاع
الامنيه في العراق على ضوء التدهور الامني
المضطرد الذي تشهده بغداد ومحافظات عرقيه
اخرى نرحب بضيفي ايضا من جديد واتحول الى
الاستاذ عبد الكريم
خلف في بغداد يعني كنا قبل الفاصل بدانا
في الاشاره الى تعاطي
حكومه حيدر العبادي مع هذه التفجيرات
عندما اقال حيدر العبادي امر
بتوقيف المسؤول الامني المحلي في حي الشعب
احدى المناطق التي استهدفت بالهجمات الا
يعتبر هذا الشيء من ذر الرمات في العقول
يعني في تعرف يعني انه في الدول المحترمه
تفجيرات بهذا الحجم واعداد بهذا الحجم من
القتلى ومن الجرحى تنتهي ب يعني استقاله
رئيس الحكومه او وزير الداخليه وليس بهذا
الاجراء الذي اقدم عليه حيدر العبادي هل
هذا كافي
برايك اولا ليس بالضروره ان يستقيل احد
يعني ما جرى في فرنسا لم يستقل لا وزير
الداخليه ولا وزير الدفاع ولا الرئيس
ثانيا هذا المسؤول المحلي اللي تم عقبته
تم عقبته ظلما يعني هذا لم يكن مسؤولا عن
التفجيرات هو كان خط الدفاع وممكن ان يكون
جزء من الضحايا هو ليس يعني مسؤولا
استخباراتيا لكي يكون عن هذه يعني مسؤول
عن اجهاض هذا العمل والعمل من هذا النوع
عمل التفجيرات ليس مسؤوله عن قياده
العمليات مسؤوله عن اجهزه الاستخبارات
المخابرات والاستخبارات والامن وهناك
وزاره للامن الوطني هذه هي الاجهزه
المسؤوله بشكل مباشر
عن هذا الموضوع ومسؤوليتها لا تقع في انها
قصرت ابدا هي الادوات التي تعمل فدي هذه
الاجهزه
مباشره لا لا ليست عقوبه يعني كان يجب ان
يكون هناك سؤال لماذا لم تستطع اجهزه
الاستخبارات ان تتشارك مع داعش التفكير
وان تقوم باختراق وقائيا وان تقدم هؤلاء
للعداله في مرحله الاستحضار لماذا اذا
لدينا قصور في الادوات حتى نصل الى هؤلاء
ونحقق هذا الكم من الاختراقات يجب ان توفر
الحكومه جمله من الاجراءات التي تدعم في
هذه الاجهزه اولها تشريعات بقوانين توسيع
صلاحياتها ونفوذها تنميه مواردها البشريه
قدراتها الفنيه والتقنيه وايضا مد اذرع
هذه الاجهزه لوصول الى المعلومه بدون
اعاقه وهذه تحتاج الى ايضا عمليات تدريب
ومزمن مع اجهزه استخبارات معروفه تتعاون
مع العراق المانيه فرنسيه امريكيه
وبريطانيه نعم طيب دع دعنا نتحدث قليلا عن
الوضع العام ال يعني الذي يسود البلاد هذه
الحاله من الشلل السياسي والسؤال الدكتور
قحطان الخفاجي حيدر العبادي قال ان
التنظيم يستفيد من حاله الشلل السياسي
الذي يعيشه العراق لماذا اذا لا يتم انهاء
حاله الشلل والاحتقان السياسي في
البلاد هذه حقيقه الامر طالما نحن في حيره
عندما نسمع مسؤولين عراق
كثر وكانهم فقط يشخصون كما نحن نفعل نحن
الذين ليس لدينا سوى عمليه تشخيص فقط انا
هذا السؤال اشاطرك به لماذا لا يتم اجراء
فعلي في هذا الحجم في الاتجاه الذهب الى
اخونا المتحدث استاذ كريم لماذا لم يتم
اتخاذ لانه الحقيقه الامر كما نقول وكما
نؤكد الخلل الكبير في طبيعه العمليه
السياسيه وفي تكوينات الاحزاب السياسيه
وفي الجهات التي اذرعها القتاليه سميها
ماشئ مليشيات او كتائب اي ما سميات
والبناء الفكري الذي بني على اساس
فسيفساء
العق القناعه الاسلاميه
وسواها جعل الامور تتمازج ما بين فلتان
سياسي فلتان ذهني عدم وجود ترابط ما بين
المجتمع وبين القياده القياده ايضا في
فلتان وعدم توافق كامله بين اجنحتها
وذراعها السياسيه والفكريه والامنيه
الاجهزه الامنيه كما شخصنا قبل قليل ذكاء
الخصم للاسف الشديد كلها تجتمع مع بعض
المشكله الكبرى هل يستطيع عبادي او
الاجهزه الامنيه ان يتجاوزوا الاحتمالات
القادمه لاعمال كهذا كهذه انا
كاستراتيجية اقول المخرجات الحكوميه صفر
لا يمكن ان تعطيه ثمره شيء ايجابي ولذلك
انا احذر احذر ااتمنى الانتباه اكثر لان
خطر داعش قد يتسع بهذا الاتجاه اكثر لهناك
اكثر من سبب طيب كي يمكن صده استاذ عبد
الكريم خلف هذا الخطر كيف يمكن صده اذا
كان فعلا التنظيم بهذا الذكاء ويستفيد من
حاله الشلل السياسي التي يعيشها العراق ما
الذي يمنع الشركاء السياسيين العراقيين من
القيام بعمليه مصالحه سياسيه تمنع استفاده
التنظيم من هذا
الوضع هو طريقين طريق امام الحكومه وبشكل
عاجل الطريق الاول هو ان تقوم بتنميه
موارد اجهزه الامن القومي وتنشئ مجلس
الامن القومي وتقوم بهيكله اجهزه
الاستخبارات هناك زياده كثيفه في هذه
الاجهزه وفوضى في عمل هذه الاجهزه وتداخل
في الساحات هذه مشكله يجب ان تحل من الان
وان يقوم صاحب القرار السياسي والدكتور
العبادي على راس الحكومه بهذا الاجراء
عاجلا هذا اولا والقضيه الثانيه هي ان
تكون هناك سلسله من الاجراءات من البرلمان
والبرلمان ان يوضع امام مسؤولياته وان
ينتقد بشكل علني وان تصفى كل القوانين
الاستثنائيه التي جاءت بعد عام 2003 وهذه
القوانين معروفه كيف قيدت العراقيين وكيف
ارغمت اخرين ان يكونوا اعداء لبلدهم هذه
القوانين يجب ان ترفع وهي كانت تسمى
قوانين العداله الانتقاليه وتحولت الى
قوانين عداله انتقاميه بايدي السياسيين
هذه القوانين يجب ان ترفع 13 سنه انتجت 31
مليار دولار خسائر في البنى التحتيه وهذا
المبلغ الضخم والهائل كلف العراق الكثير
وتراجعات على كل المستويات اذا عليهم ان
يفهموا ان سياساتهم هذه التي جاءت بهذه
الامور عليها ان تتوقف دكتور قحطان هل هذا
يمكن ان
يحدث لا لن يحدث نهائيا اختي العزيزه
لاننا امام عمليه سياسيه ورموز للعمليه
السياسيه كمن يغزلون صوف بمغزل عسج عسج
نبات عندنا شائك في العراق فلا يمكن ان
ينتج المغزل الذي اشواك من الصوف شيء
ايجابيا اختي العزيزه انا وهنا ارجو ان
ناخذ دقائق صغيره ان في العراق كوادر
امنيه تعجز السي اي اي ان تمتلك مثلها
ولان السي اي اي ادركت خطر بعض الجز
الامنيه العراقيه الغت كليه الامن القومي
وسواها فينا كثير من القدرات بمختلف
الاختصاصات ولكن حتى هذه الخاصات الراقيه
العاليه الامكانيه لا يمكن ان تعمل في ظل
عمليه سياسيه خاطئه وظل اجهزه امنيه متهر
لذلك عايز هناك مهمه تصحيح المسار السياسي
لعمليه برمتها والملف الامني بما فيه
القوه المسلحه غير النظاميه يجب ان نضع
لها حد حتى يمكن ان يكون هناك ايجابيه في
النتائج نعم شكرا لك دكتور قحطان الخفاجي
وشكرا للاستاذ عبد الكريم خلف من
بغداد شكرا لكم اطيب المنى والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء
ه